how's it going sorry breasts - purify
you look a little tired that Jimmy J I
got its balls what the [ __ ] that's kind
of gross
it's like a tiny little clip coming out
anyway that was a guest intro probably
and all of it ignore that anyway we're
gonna we're gonna go to sleep there we
go
it looks like G minutes it's that
panties on the wall it looks like this
video isn't so gay after all unless
unless those are from a man I guess I
should just stop okay another day
another gay [ __ ] hey how's it going okay
let's do a new quest for us before I say
something else smart he had marbles
there they are
alright perfect I want to try something
you brush your brows told me to do so
let's try this
alright let's try this again because I
fail it's fun
all right there we go oh stop betting
may i what the [ __ ] he's a goldfish did
you see that [ __ ]
I'm not a Dolph at this fails really
hard all you wanna [ __ ] with me
oh you wanna [ __ ] with me I'm [ __ ]
kill all of you
bet Jess stop ducking stop ducking I'm
gonna fart on you sorry that failed I'm
sorry that failed
okay let's start anew Christ hey man
how's it going good alright alright
let's head to the Liberty Liberty labra
wow that wasn't me
Bach that's bass a Mac thank God
wrong part of town alright what is this
amigo Oh ciao amigo come aside your help
yes tell me what it is
what is that amigo Johnny and his goons
were hassling me about algae how could
they I scored even crazier he thinks
algae is trying to put the moves its
algae I'm gonna fight a guy and Lola I
know it's crazy
no blood yeah everyone knows I didn't
know that getting back here until Johnny
comes to his senses
where is he I don't know I know he was
working on a math project for Hatrack
with Cornelius okay maybe he knows where
algae is probablemente oh yes you know
the scrawny kid in the acting Club he
did an amazing Juliet in the school play
no grade point average all right
four point eight [ __ ] what I go okay
but yeah anyway no I
we're gonna go I wasn't really good
Juliette - in school when cosplay I
played I played
oh [ __ ] ball grabber I play that your
layout that many times I actually play
the donkey in Romeo and Juliet I did I
was a finance donkey where's algae what
are they doing dancing around bro bro
come on it's like they're milking oh
alright it's [ __ ] smacking time marbles
slow nah [ __ ]
come here back I say it's supposed to
trip nah he goes ah stop Oh
Salo to my little frame by the ginger
shallot he was lying when he told but
where is he then that's for me
that is for me and my mama save it for
me and my mama girl where is he then
he's not even here he's in town all
right
it's a Vespa time sorry friend
one of these guys doing all right let's
go and get Best Buy and then we party
you guys for this press epic three six
day
oh hello senorita what's that
wanna help me with my dick I don't know
okay I'm sorry
let's jump on the vest back best I would
never hit you and they move on the [ __ ]
out of the way nub [ __ ] out of the way I
told them to move they can't complain
alright let's go and save Aldi well we
killed 50 other people out of my way
women
alright Shaka
well that's the best part
riding on my Vespa riding riding riding
all my bears that's the best song I
could come up with all right let me try
harder I could best buy with me and my
creature why do I even try it's not
about that sorry about that
nipple twist nipple twist ah best spot
don't you dare touch him oh [ __ ] I gotta
go I didn't do anything I just twisted
nut ball it's normal
epic 360 epic
never twice
oh [ __ ] we're at the bread the bad part
of town press all right where the [ __ ]
is he
what are we are here
I find it wait oh yeah what the [ __ ]
good that's free it's just a hundred
bucks
that's nothing to a man of your means I
have to steal it off of my women oh look
at you both
you're pathetic but she likes me I don't
believe this
you both better get over listen we got
to get out of here before Johnny Vincent
sees you hanging out with his girlfriend
algae you take the girl's bike Chad
better pedal for both legs I got a
feeling I'm headed from started her
vagina all right well I gotta save this
the plot thickens so much stuff going up
whoa did she poppin algie's on a girl's
bike oh no I remember every word Oh what
the [ __ ] I remember back in there when
you were younger and if you ever ride on
a girl's bike it was like oh you can't
let should random people also why bother
we can battles get the [ __ ] away
I don't know it's so stupid Oh girls bye
okay I the gobsmacked what's your
problem I have a penis so it's okay what
what okay
shoot him huh I should just focus on
there sometime that's very distracting
okay that hit him in the head guys shoot
them while their dad why the [ __ ] not
nah woah he killed himself woo that was
[ __ ] epic sorry about that
headshot nefesh [ __ ] [ __ ] shot I
don't know nothing right love [ __ ]
them when they're already dead it's so
[ __ ] awesome dad you all you got do
not these guys really want to keep care
about that guy's girlfriend I mean who
gives a [ __ ] if my friend said that his
girlfriend was just kidding good I would
be like well good riddance you don't
need that girl anymore there's no need
to beat anyone up for that it's my
opinion step on it and it's a good buck
whoa there's super slow Elyse actually
are really [ __ ] good bicyclist who
would have thought what are you doing
what are you doing
it's like I hate my life I don't even
know I am doing this never mind
I have to do it super sad and depressed
they have a lot of bikes and a lot of
friends well no one hits you and you
know I don't want to be friends
I'm not hitting you come here algae
Jesus
here's your stupid friend Jeannie fart
and this is honest no respect
[ __ ] no respect is the most
valuable respect em anyway
it's up get you no no I don't know chefs
she's dancing to learn me in okay look
at something else I want to try
something else
go away stop following me
she's creepy but do it see if I give a
[ __ ] alright alright here we go here we
go
you want some of this no no no
what's most awkward laugh ever come back
here alright let me try and hit him
instead wedgie bullying little kills I
don't give a [ __ ] sorry we shouldn't do
that no no it was a man and what's it
man it wasn't man I swear to God what
man photography I want to go to this car
welcome to photography class
I'm miss Phillips alright I'll be
handing out your cameras and first
assignment in a moment ok good what's my
first assignment tech pictures of
banners located oh that's boring
finally alright we're done yes it's my
dick sorry I have nothing hey girlfriend
I like how all the girls in this school
loves me loser
no I don't mean to push I see you later
I love bunny thing what's she doing I
don't wanna I don't wanna [ __ ] [ __ ] her
is that what you wanted
ok
I wanted to touch there but it's funny
that's what I did when I was in first
grade
balla balla ah come on I didn't do it
she liked it she [ __ ] liked it our
trim really shows your sensitive side
yes yes indeed very nice conversation
we're having here
I like how you stroke your hair teacher
and I love that sweater that you have
there like white suits your skin it it
complex your abilities quite stunningly
yes that's what I said so how are you
today miss no but really how are you
of course I see how it is yes I don't
even know what I was going with that all
right
photo check it what's that my fingers
going inside the camera but no one seems
to give a [ __ ] my hand is stuck in this
camera help me
glasshouse what is this oh is that
teacher again huh
yes what are you young man very well are
you a high ball yeah sure actually maybe
you're a little young better keep this
out of harm's way
good thinking good thinking are you
gonna be all right sir it's that pompous
ass Patrick what you bad-mouthing me all
around a staff room why he keeps calling
me a drunk one Mason think that's
possible you are the most inspired he's
trying to turn miss Phillips against me
well sir when people say bad things
about what I do I like to prove him
wrong really Wow
yeah he's showing a nobler side of
yourself rising above it no
a machete I'd like to show that they
massively underestimated the force that
they were dealing with and then really
give him something to complain about
good me too
all right let's beat the [ __ ] out of
those people travel to the school
parking lot all right where are we going
I know nobody's no one I chuckle dude a
bunch of window where the witness Oh
over the top
equip your skateboard to get closer oh
no way
awesome it's not that fast this is
actually slower than before you shot
come on
why do I have to do this I can just
follow it seriously at least if it was
faster or it was like better uphill or
something it's probably better I feel
not I think about it but there is no up
hell this is pointless
c'est comme pointless so multi couplets
so say say say italiana all right that's
good was there where am i holding anyway
seriously where the [ __ ] am i holding
what I I'm just gonna stop asking
questions now yes
being alone it's
it's hard just like Santa Clauses when
it's really hot
honk honking I think that was when the
world
as in name
now this is fun gameplay I've been doing
this good I mean that register played is
pretty nice I think it says PDR which
stands for base drop random which is
pretty much dubstep enough in and then
nutshell that's pretty good and there
that description
alright destroy as much as you can over
the house obvious such as potted plants
windows okay
alright we're gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
started with this [ __ ] car
I am [ __ ] your car I'm [ __ ] your
car with my neck manifests how do we get
in there I [ __ ] the pun pun pops
it's the props oh it's a cop [ __ ] can I
even kill cops oh I just like nipples
stop rubbing mine it's illegal shed I
really fail that quest but it's kind of
boring anyway summits will take a new
one which one should I pick I'll let you
typically Greta I can't hear you still
can't hear you
okay anyway I'm gonna guess that you
wanted this one because I might consider
it yep I care about what you think okay
so aqua Barry Russ I have spin a good
day it's been a good day
we're go to sleep and like a 5/5 Android
subscribe comment read today and I'll
see you next episode I have a mic I'll
be browsing stay awesome
what